the Anchorman movies are already
hilarious but the bloopers I'm the funny
up to 11. Chrome improvise condom names
to run sexual fascination with Mrs
Butterworth these laugh out loud without
tags prove that sometimes the funniest
moments don't make the Final Cut
diving into a character and delivering
hours upon hours of ad-libbing is a near
impossible feat for many actors however
while feral naturally adopted the overly
arrogant characteristics of news anchor
Von burgundy from the moment he puts on
the three-piece suit hey everyone
come and see how good I look one of the
best examples of Farrell's aptitude for
the character occurs when he has left to
his own devices before the Evening News
camera rolls burgundy often warms up his
vocal chords with original tongue
twisters or obnoxious screaming
[Music]
the deleted scene had scene showcase how
one of these lines was too silly even
for feral while repeating a line about
the Human Torch being denied a bank loan
farewell and the behind the scenes crew
were doubled over in laughter
farewell and the rest of the on-screen
performers deserve most of the credit
for making the Anchorman movies
Monumental comedic achievements however
director Adam McKay is just as
responsible for a significant portion of
the hilarity McKay Co wrote the scripts
for both Anchorman movies with feral and
his humor is peppered throughout the
stories however the director had just as
much influence on the improvisational
humor as some other stars throughout
many of the bloopers and outtakes McKay
can be heard hollering lines and jokes
from behind the camera the best example
of McKay's cleverness comes in an
Anchorman 2 scene in the scene feral is
discussing breast implants with co-star
Paul Rudd and cracks that they now use
Taco Meats as a filler but when McKay
suggests nickels from off-screen both
Rudd and feral have a quick laugh
of course even an Anchorman of Ron
burgundy's caliber wouldn't be anywhere
without a superstar news team thankfully
the movie did an outstanding job of
filling out the crew behind the channel
4 news the diverse group of funny men
include David keckner Paul Rudd and
Steve Carell well fans got to know the
entire Channel 4 News team well over the
course of two films many deleted scenes
helped audiences learn even more about
them much of the content deleted from
the original and command film was
collected into the director video
counterpart film wake up Ron Burgundy
the last movie however the blooper reel
for the first Anchorman showcases a
collection of unused taglines for the
Four Season stars of San Diego's
favorite news filmed in the same tone as
a short TV commercial a channel 4 news
crew delivers a quick line that
perfectly encapsulates their characters
burgundy fittingly says they're like a
good strong lady in a tasty BLT
meanwhile Corral's not so bright
weatherman character brick Nails it on
the head saying when there's weather to
report I report the weather
while the first sangaman's assortment of
comedians helped make the movie a
success and Command 2 brought in so many
well-known actors that the film
struggled to fit them all in cleverly
the sequel doubled down on a famous
scene from the first movie but a Channel
4 News team got into a tussle with a
rival group of anchors however in
Anchorman 2 The Fight got much bigger
involving news teams from all over the
world furthermore each group features
some of the biggest names in Hollywood
including Will Smith and Jim Carrey with
so many funny people in one place
shooting the fight scene was
understandably a rambunctious occasion
and the younger man 2 bloopers do not
disappoint in showing off the chaos when
I'll take shows how difficult it was for
Gary to remember his Canadian news
anchor name without what the hell's my
name the entire events must have been
too much for everyone because even
comedy veteran Will Smith wound up
crying probably from laughing so hard
filming a movie as hilarious as
Anchorman with our laughing sounds like
an insurmountable job so it's no wonder
that the majority of the outtakes and
bloopers on this list features someone
bursting into laughter however a few
scenes went off the rails without
giggling most notably a deep
conversation from burgundy had with his
beloved pet dog Baxter in a scene from
the first movie farewell's character is
greeted by his loyal canine after
returning home from work when burgundy
tells Baxter about his love life in an
extended outtake he says I think it was
Aristotle who said come children let me
tell you a tale about
ships and whales
in an unforgettable scene from the first
Anchorman Ryan fantana shares a secret
to success with women revealing his
off-brand cologne Sex Panther so
obviously when it came to making a
sequel to Anchorman the writers wanted
to develop a similar scene in hopes of
recreating the magic for Anchorman 2
Fontana's cupboard gets much larger than
holding one bottle of cologne rather he
has an entire Shrine of condoms and
lubricants that he shares with the rest
of the channel 4 news team the scene is
a hysterical moment during the finalized
film but the bloopers take it up another
notch analyzing different condoms the
actors improvised an assortment of lines
around their individual purposes as
Veronica Corningstone Christina
Applegate plays an even-tempered
professional thrown into the clown show
known as Channel 4 News burgundy and
crew grow to resent the anchor woman
stepping into a role beside them so they
had to plan to ruin her career this is
showcased when the news team attempts to
throw her off by making faces and
gestures while she's live on air that's
calling Stone remains completely unfazed
I'm Veronica Corningstone
and thanks for stopping by San Diego
however as easy as Applegate's character
made it look in the movie the actress
had a much harder time keeping a
straight face one blooper depicts Apple
gay giggling as Paul Rudd and David
keckner taunts her while she reads her
news report
as weatherman breaks hamland Steve
Carell quickly became a fan favorite and
delivered some of the most quotable
lines in the Anchorman movies I Love
Lamp Rod admitted in an interview with
GQ that one scene with Corel made him
laugh the hardest the moment in question
involved Corral's character eating a
wrap for lunch however the meal
consisted of a used coffee filter
wrapped around a cigarette butt and
loose change
aside from Farrell the next biggest name
on screen in Anchorman was Paul Rudd in
an interview as GQ Rudd pointed to one
particular scene when he struggled to
hold it together it takes place after
the channel 4 news team gets into a
street fight with a rival crew from
another news channel licking their
wounds in one burgundy's office feral
delivers the line and proud of you
fellas you all kept your head on a
swivel and that's what you got to do
when you find yourself in a vicious
fight the improvised bet proved too much
for the veteran rud as he remembers
breaking character and laughing that's
not in the script script or anything I
and I was like took me by surprise
meanwhile the blooper reel reveals that
feral also couldn't help but laugh at
his own impromptu joke
David cagner's performance as champ kind
rounded out the Fantastic Four of Shadow
4. as he uttered some of the crew's most
obscene comments
know get a couple cocktails in me start
a fire in someone's kitchen surely
Captain enjoyed playing the role as
Trump resembles other characters he has
played however when it came to returning
to do the Anchorman sequel the actor may
have gotten a little too excited in a
scene where champ kind Embraces his old
friend Ron Burgundy the hood gets
awkward and a Tut aggressive the moment
is even funnier in the outtakes as
cagnet takes the uncomfortable moment
further
over the course of two movies there is
enough Anchorman to leave everyone's
sides hurting from laughter however Rod
found one scene so funny that he
couldn't even get through it during an
interview with the ringer he mentions a
scene from the first film where feral
says milk was a bad choice which was
nearly ruined by laughter but it was a
joke from a feral in the sequel that
really took the cake for Rudd drawing
the scene in question burgundy is so
depressed from losing everything that he
remarks the other day I pleasured myself
to the image of Mrs Buttersworth
thankfully this hilarious moment also
made it into the blooper reels
the hilarity continued in the Anchorman
2 scene in which the channel 4 news team
arrived at burgundy's house to cheer him
up wrapped in a blanket and suffering
from depression farewell's character is
completely over the top with his
self-deprecation much of the frustration
of his friends however for the actors it
was easily one of the most entertaining
days of filming drawing one outtake from
the scene burgundy compared to suffering
to that of the Elephant Man he then does
an impression of the Elephant Man which
instantly breaks right
forever spent his entire career
surrounded by some of Hollywood's
funniest people the active famously
makes everybody around him break
character what he improvises and takes
things unexpected levels it is only fair
that once in a blue moon the comedic
Dynamo loses control and ruins are seen
by laughing however in Anchorman 2 feral
is best to buy an actor that you would
least suspect to make him laugh Harrison
Ford in the movie Ford plays a superstar
Anchorman who does not have a soft spot
for burgundy during one of the film's
few serious moments when Phil's
character talks about being responsible
for the death of a window washer Pharaoh
can't help but burst into laughter
one of the funniest gags from Anchorman
2 involve champ kind leaving the news
business behind and opening a fried
chicken restaurant the movie explains
Our Kind fakes an accident at work and
uses settlement money to open his joint
however in an effort to save money
keckner's character explains that he
uses bats instead of poultry amusingly
keckner was on top of using his
character's situation and improvised
many jokes about using other possible
Meats one outtake finds feral cracking
up after Kakuna delivers this line I
figure after it's been in a deep fryer
it's no longer human
among the best parts of watching the
Anchorman movies is catching the
never-ending assortment of celebrity
cameos however two cameos proved
perfectly fitting considering feral and
McKay shed a long history of
collaborating with them on Saturday
Night Live Tina Fey and Amy polar seen
the sea entered their way into the news
team Royal Rumble in Anchorman 2
representing an all-female news crew
polar and Fey together in front of a
camera equals comedy magic there are
multiple bloopers and outtakes
showcasing the non-stop giggling and
joking the two women brought to the set
fan polar also improvised many hilarious
lines during their short appearance
including this gem I'll ride your
mustache all the way to hell
in a hilarious outtake from Anchorman 2
feral is guilty of blurting out the
wrong cast member's name when sharing a
scene with keckner frewell incidentally
calls kegner brick which happens to be
the first name of Steve Carell's
character where most actors would take
the simple mistake in stride Kakuna
hilariously punches feral by telling him
Brick's dead
the Anchorman movies are so funny that
even when the actors are keeping for the
script they still can't help but laugh
for instance in Anchorman 2 Root's
character shares an upcoming expose
about the powers and Mysteries of the
human vagina which proves to be too much
for feral in an outtake amusingly run
does not let up calling it an explosive
piece she almost puts feral on the floor
in Anchorman 2 Steve Carell played the
Channel 4 Weatherman with as much
Ridiculousness as he did the first time
around between delivering a eulogy at
his own funeral to getting married to
the love of his life brick also had a
far more significant role in the sequel
Rick was a great man really and I will
miss him so much and I will not rest
until I find his killer however that did
not mean that he was not up to his old
gags sure corel's character doesn't eat
another coffee filter but the bloopers
show he had just as many struggles
chowing down food for instance one
outside shows him spitting beer all over
himself
a significant challenge that many movie
productions face when filming outside of
a studio is excessive noise but
seriously airplanes and helicopters
thankfully when a movie like Anchorman
is fully loaded with comedic Talent even
an unforeseen obstruction can become a
side-splitting joke hilarious see you in
a loud helicopter ruined the scene for
Anchorman crawl joked that his personal
transport had arrived gripping that he
has a helicopter to travel him around
San Diego as an ongoing joke for
burgundy the first time audiences met
the local Anchorman at the beginning of
the first film in 2004 he stepped out of
her Channel 4 News Chopper in an
additional scene involving some kinds
and Orthodox fried chicken restaurant
David keckner Gets beaten by his own
joke when Rudd delivers a line that
completely catches him off guard in the
outtake kegner's character asks his
friend to name a meat to which Fontana
replies chicken out of all the potential
answers Kakuna was obviously not
expecting that one and instantaneously
burst into laughter
one of the most awkward Parts about
being an actor or actress must be
sharing extremely intimate scenes with a
coaster so we imagine it was almost
impossible for Christina Applegate to
keep a straight face drunga and command
bed scene with feral it's particularly
hard to forget the part of the scene in
which burgundy and Applegate's Veronica
Corningstone make out after all
aggressive biting of lips and far too
much tongue transformed a standard
kissing session into comedy gold for
audiences of course Farrell's goofball
Antics had Applegate cracking up as seen
in the film's blooper reel
not many performers can match corel's
level of hilarity seven seasons on the
office prove that
however when seeking someone to play
opposite Corel for Anchorman 2 McKay
knocked it out of the park by hiring
Saturday Night Live Alum Kristen Wiig
wig and Corral delivered an on-screen
connection that was perfect and better
described as pure awkwardness what makes
their offbeat romance even more
entertaining is the fact that much of
their time on screen together was
completely improvised the bloopers
released for Anchorman 2 of pad to the
brim with outtakes featuring Corel and
wig making each other laugh that said
one scene between the two goes
completely off the rails when Corral
tells wig that his favorite food is pee
one burgundy's turn around in Anchorman
2 occurs when he realizes that he wants
to deliver America the news that they
want to hear like why the USA is the
greatest place on Earth before that
however burgundy was in serious trouble
of finding his voice while in the
National Spotlight the scene between
Farrell and Dylan Baker who plays
burgundy's boss is vital to pushing the
movie forward and resulted in one of the
movie's greatest bloopers in the scene
Baker's character gets mad at burgundy's
ideas and finally says that's not news
Farrell is supposed to respond on the
line about grabbing popcorn and watching
the end of the world but breaks
character before he can even get the
words out
there is another Anchorman star that
does not get enough credit burgundy's
loyal pep Pub Baxter surprisingly this
fairy actor was almost a reason the
Beloved comedy film received a more
mature rating than PG-13 Baxter appears
in much of the first film including one
particularly memorable scene where he's
kicked off a bridge by Jack Black the
dog plays a pivotal role in the plot and
in burgundy's heart
you know how to cut to the core of me
Baxter however McKay revealed in the
director's commentary that Baxter nearly
earned Anchorman in our rating the pub
had a habit of revealing his genitalia
and his Parts can be seen throughout the
film apparently the Motion Picture
Association of America abides by a
strict rule stating that a movie will
get an instant R for more than five
seconds of close-up images of male
genitalia and that includes animals so
McKay was forced to edit out several
shots of the cute fluffy pup and is
overly apparent parts